- I have a very distinct memory
of like being 10 years old,
and I tried to talk to other kids my age,
and it did not go well.
I like started making animal noises.
(blowing sound)
(happy string music)
- I don't know that you can say like one,
one thing.
- It's different for everyone.
- Personally for me
like I was taught by my parents.
So it was literally school at home.
- Homeschooling is where
your house is your school.
- Really depends on what you wanna learn
and how you want to learn it.
(happy string music)
- Yes.
- Yeah, I think even if you
don't know that you're awkward
a lot of times homeschool
people end up being very-
- You are.
- I think it depends, 'cause
like you don't seem awkward.
I'm awkward.
But like I don't know if that's
because I was homeschooled
or just because I'm awkward.
- Oh of course.
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Homeschooling is really
good because it allows kids
to learn at their own pace.
I have learning disabilities,
and I just needed a little
extra time to catch up.
- Everyday is a field trip.
Let's go to a museum
or let's go to the movies.
- Oh I went to a cadaver lab.
Don't most people do that probably?
No?
No we didn't do the dissecting,
but we did look at a
body that was dissected,
and they showed us like a brain
and they showed us some testicles
and they showed us like layers of fat
to show like what fat
looks like on the inside
and that freaked me out.
- Because there's so much freedom
there is sometimes more of an opportunity
for it to go wrong.
- Basically my parents
aren't great at math.
Who needs math?
- I didn't have any
friends 'til I was like 14.
- So I didn't get friends
'til I was like 19.
I was like way older.
- Homeschoolers definitely sleep longer
than public schoolers.
- Depends what dope activity my mom
or dad had planned for us.
- My homeschooling was not
like most regular homeschoolers
because I grew up Muslim.
We had a more structural schedule.
You had to wake up at
five for your prayer.
Yeah, you had to wake up for prayer,
and then after prayer
you had to make sure you
got breakfast before seven,
and then we did martial
arts after meditation time.
- I was never lonely.
There were plenty of
kids in my neighborhood.
There were plenty of other
homeschool families that I knew.
- I wouldn't say it makes you lonely,
but I would say it makes
you more of a loner.
- I wouldn't say
homeschoolers are any smarter
than public or private or whatever.
- Homeschoolers are
typically really passionate
about like a smaller number of things,
and they're really good at those things.
- I wouldn't say I'm book smart.
So we're smarter in the
aspect of being an adult.
- I was homeschooled all the
way up until I started college,
and I took like the SATs
just like anyone else.
- We're like a really
good entrance I'd say.
Bribery.
- I didn't find success
by going to college.
I just found it doing my own thing.
- My parents are very anti-establishment,
anti-government.
They wanted to teach us
what they wanted to teach us
without being told like this
is what your kid's gonna learn.
- It could depend on like
what your learning pace is,
where your like cultural or
like religious beliefs are
or if you just don't like
the schools in your area.
- Honestly most of the
time it's just because
your parents wanted you
to learn things at home
and learn things a different way.
- Homeschoolers are super normal.
- Yeah.
(happy guitar music)
(blowing sound)